hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones finale video oh
my god they paid off so many big moments
some of the things we were expecting
definitely a few surprises so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet so many things that they
had to wrap up I think the biggest
surprise was they went back to the door
and storyline like oh they found a
reason and I guess you could look at
this as the show's version of door and
master plan it's just that it's more
Varys that's behind the plan
so he's found his supporters all the
Martel's pretty pretty much everyone
that Cersei has done wrong which makes
you think about what's going to be
happening in the north with king crow
like when Daenerys comes to Westeros
they're mostly talking about what's
going on in the south with all these
alliances they haven't talked too much
about what's going on in the north so
there was a lot of imagery going back to
season 2 season 3 during the war of the
five kings especially with the reverse
red wedding for a pious moment
mass-transit be damned I was totally
happy with that moment even though it
throws logic out the window a little bit
with the way people move across the
world so fast so top 10 WTF all explain
book stuff as we go there was a lot of
book moments in here but obviously
they've changed a couple things because
there are characters on the show that
are dead in the books they're characters
in the books that are still alive so Dan
and Dave said a lot of the way they're
building drama and the final two seasons
is in working with the characters that
they do have like Mad Queen Cersei but
here we go
top 10 WTF number 10 everybody getting
ready for the trial so this is just an
amazing use of silence I mean there was
a little bit of music but for a large
part of this episode it was dead quiet
it just makes things feel so much more
serious compared to other episodes when
their drums banging when people are
running with like Aria is chased through
the streets so I always give mad props
to the show for the way it uses music or
the way it doesn't use music as is the
case with the preparation for the trials
so number nine is lures confessing all
of his crimes he just he confesses to
everything completely they give him the
special faith militant tattoo just like
carve it right into his forehead you can
totally see in his eyes that he believes
everything he is saying you have to
remember that Margaery who seems like
she supports the faith is really putting
on an act she's just trying to survive
but the problem is she's been trying to
save her brother and it almost seems
like she can at least up until Cersei
gets her way but number eight pycelle is
killed by the little birds and while it
isn't funny there's a certain comedy
to it like as he's getting right he's
kind of being very smug he tells the
that he's going to pay her later
so it just is fun the way they had these
scenes juxtaposed with the Laura scenes
like Loras is admitting tallest crimes
all of his falsehoods in accepting the
gods and it's almost like pycelle as
being very false and that he wears the
chain of grand maester and is supposed
to have a life of service even though
he's enjoying all these things that he's
not supposed to so him dying is almost
like a form of Justice
like Qyburn as evil as he seems is
really just a scientist that wants to
serve he has no grand ambitions he
doesn't bear you any ill will
he just serving the will of the Queen
Queen Cersei so because Qyburn seems
like he's one of the few people that has
some sense in him that surround Cersei
I'll be curious to see how he reacts to
Varys and all these other people all
these other forces that are swirling
around but of course number seven Lancel
finds the Wildfire I think we all
expected it to happen it wasn't so much
about surprise it was more about
suspense even though it's all meant to
be very cinematic the way they film it
all the props that they use it's
actually fairly ingenious using little
candles as fuses to set the wildfire off
but I was so happy that they blew the
great Sept up instead of the red keep
because there's wildfire all over King's
Landing but I guess you could look at
Cersei is having used all of it but the
interesting thing is is that that seen
the footage is taken directly from
brands vision so now we know that bran
not only sees into the past but he also
gets visions of the future what about
inside the great Sept though as Margaery
like the wheels and her head are
starting to turn Oh Cersei doesn't want
to come she's not showing up maybe she's
up to something we need to get out of
here right now I feel like this is the
writers not trying to throw marjorie
under the bus even though she's always
been a secondary character to Cersei so
she's always one of the biggest if not
the biggest character in King's Landing
so anytime someone comes up against her
you know that she's probably just going
to railroad them so I feel like this is
them just trying to balance the Margaery
character out who she was much bigger on
the TV show than she was in the book she
wasn't that big of a character in the
books but number 5 speaking of wildfire
I bet you they have plans for how to
make more of that in the Citadel this
was actually some of the rare comedy in
the episode just like this really funny
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
bureaucracy moment where he enters the
library and just this awkward silence
just a little physical comedy
as he tries to explain what's going on
yes sorry we didn't tell you maester
aemon died
the old bear died jon snow's been Lord
Commander a whole bunch of stuff has
happened but we've been so busy that's
why we haven't sent a raven to let you
know what's up so i think i've done a
few videos about the Citadel but we've
never actually got to see inside it so
it's just like this very Harry Potter
Doctor Who moment where it's bigger on
the inside just his magnificent reveal
as Samwell looks like he's about ready
to cry so happy but the Citadel itself
is where everyone studies to be a
maester to forge their chain you take
new areas of study to forge a different
link on the chain you learn medicine you
learn Raven Ryu even learned stuff about
the occult they're all different links
that you can forge in the maesters chain
but the thing is is that it takes a long
time it's not like going to college it's
not like a four-year degree if Samwell
we're going by the books it would be
like a 10-year plan so the show is
probably going to speed things up he'll
probably find a way to send messages to
Jon Snow about things that he's learned
ways to fight the White Walkers
I feel like wildfire would come in handy
but the alchemists guild is different
from the maesters so the show might bend
some logic like Arya teleporter logic
bending so the Samwell finds the plans
for how to make wildfire or you know
something that is of great value they
gave for Samwell so happy for him and
Gilly she'll end up having to stay
somewhere in Old Town because they don't
allow women in the Citadel but you get
the idea they're in Old Town now for the
foreseeable future
number four is Tommen jumping out the
window like bran was pushed out the
window nice mirror for that only this
time it's Circe's fault it's not Jamie's
fault it's funny how they do things like
that but I just I love the way they that
scene off where he very calmly takes his
crown off there's dead silence there's
no music playing over the scene and he
slowly runs out just Swan dives out the
window he was definitely not my favorite
character but he had his moments so I'm
sad to see him go but it was really
awesome the way they pulled it off and
what it means for Circe's character the
fact that she's just going to go off the
deep end now because there's no children
to balance her out so number three
Cersei versus shame none round - this
was so amazing in this coupled with
Cersei being crowned queen of the Seven
Kingdoms Cersei Lannister was crowned
queen of the Seven Kingdoms not Cersei
Baratheon so that's actually an
important point so now it really is
going to be the Kingdom rallying against
the Lannisters the Lannisters under sir
see are now more true villains of the
show but didn't you just love how she's
a slowly wine boarding like she's
waterboarding the shame done with wine
walking around confessing all the crimes
the thing that she refused to do before
when she was at her mercy oh I had sex
with my brother I killed my husband
she's talking about Robert completely
unapologetic about any of her
transgressions she's like I did it
because it felt good I had sex with my
brother because it felt good to have him
inside me she didn't say anything about
loving him so that actually might be a
cue for things between them later but I
love the way Dan and Dave talked about
Jaime's character as he's kind of seeing
the damage that Circe's wrought and
what's what's been going on since he's
been gone he says that he is now super
afraid of Cersei just as afraid of
Cersei is anybody else would be because
she is now full-on mad queen she did the
thing that the Mad King tried to do but
did not end up Jaime stopped him before
he blew everyone up with wildfire so
even though there's this amazing victory
for searching this episode she defeats
all of her enemies in one fell swoop but
she walks away feeling like the villain
even though she's one of the
protagonists of the show she's one of
the main characters she hasn't really
been a villain in the past even though
she's been a super but now she is
more of a true villain than she's ever
been I will say the most compelling
human villain on the show right now
because we still have the night king and
he is very inhuman so can you not just
wait for Daenerys versus Cersei that is
just going to be so much fun number two
Daenerys sails for Westeros with her
mighty ships I love how they have
Targaryen sails on a bunch of them
that's also a bit of a bend in logic it
would take them forever to make all
those sails so again it's just like the
show compressing time like okay we want
this really awesome image of this
Targaryen fleet sailing west with
dragons overhead with this really
hopeful music like oh my god
fortune and glory this is going to be so
amazing what an amazing way to tee up an
alliance with Dorne to what do you offer
your heart's content fire and blood and
of course my number one no surprise here
brand finishes the tower of joy vision
sees how Jon Snow was born how Ned
became honorbound to protect him from
Robert and everyone that might want to
kill him in this really tender moment I
really love with the actress Lyanna
stark here did with this obviously it's
the different actors because she's much
older than the last flashback that we
saw but it was still a very amazing
scene even though it was very
a brief in the way they transition to
John snows face there was really two
reasons for them to do that one it
looked amazing it was very cinematic way
to film that transition scene but two it
was a way to tell people who don't read
the books or don't read about the
theories who that baby was like oh we're
looking at John Snow here because leonov
kind of softly whispered the name to Ned
you almost couldn't hear it if you
didn't turn the volume way way up but
then John is promptly crowned king in
the north
because Lyanna Mormon of course she
saves the day she remembers for the
north so bonus top moment is Liana more
meant for the wind helping the north
remember and I know I haven't really
talked about the Sansa Littlefinger
stuff really what I feel like is going
on in that storyline he I mean he has a
big reveal where he's like I remain true
to my conviction by telling myself over
and over that I'm going to make it a
reality it's me sitting on the Iron
Throne with you that was a surprise to
me the fact that he wanted to be on the
Iron Throne with Sansa I always figured
he would try to do it the more legit way
by marrying sweet Robin to her and then
try to put them on the throne this is a
little more insidious so they're trying
to show you that even though
Littlefinger has helped the good guys
out so to speak he is still very much
not a good guy in that look on Santa's
face is just like oh god I'm gonna have
to deal with this for another two years
so when I say that what I mean is is the
Littlefinger plot in this northern
storyline it's just going to be used to
create drama and intrigue in the next
two seasons because there were so many
big wins after this big battle in
episode 9 that there's not a lot of
drama anymore like the entirety of the
North swears fealty to King crow Jon
Snow King in the north
just like Robb Stark so there had to be
a way to create some drama because
they're not quite ready to bring the
White Walkers south of the wall so we
have Littlefinger like oh you want your
mustache twirling villain I guess that's
my cue to step out so Littlefinger is a
little contrived in these moments but
he's really filling the vacuum left by
Ramsay in a more insidious way he is
definitely the most evil person in this
room he's the only person that isn't
cheering Sansa even spot she actually
seems genuinely happy for Jon Snow and I
feel like even if she gets led astray by
Littlefinger Dan and Dave were like in
this moment she's a little jealous of
Jon I feel like she's going to do the
right thing but you can see how Jon Snow
might be stepping on some of Santa's
toes now they're going to have some
awkwardness at the beginning of neck
season but hopefully they don't mire
themselves in like that like
what I'd really like to see is salsa be
like no no no you know you you take this
seat this is yours I'm totally happy to
be here as long as you consult me and
some of the drama will come when Jon
Snow makes decisions without her so yeah
it might get a little soapy but I don't
think it's gonna devolve into
let me know in the comments though what
was your guy's favorite moment from the
episode was it Cersei being Queens was
it the Jon Snow reveal I definitely say
there were so many things that we
expected to happen in this episode that
happened I was so happy that they paid
them off like the Jon Snow stuff
Cersei being a true villain I didn't
expect her to be crowned queen of the
Seven Kingdoms
that along with Arya Frey pie is
probably the biggest surprises for me
from the episode but I almost forgot to
talk about Frey pies so Frey pies is a
thing from the books like Walder Frey's
family being cooked in do pies then
those pies being served to him but the
Arya stuff is like is the off-book stuff
so you see how Arya is probably going to
be coming back crossing names off her
list in the next season so even though
I'm really excited to see Daenerys butt
heads with Cersei I feel like if
anyone's gonna kill Cersei now it'll
either be Jaime or it'll be Arya and I
think it'll probably be Arya it really
does feel like the show would give Arya
that kill now that she is back in
Westeros and kind of running around
independent so going into season seven
now we have the king in the north we
have Queen Cersei then further in the
south we have the Daenerys Alliance so
it's almost like Westeros is now broken
into three different pieces we have Jon
Snow up in the north Cersei ruling in
the middle and then Daenerys ruling down
in the south so you can kind of see how
the show is plotting Daenerys as route
out she'll slowly make her way up to the
wall she'll have to go through Cersei to
get there she'll get the Johnson out
like Dario's like who are you going to
marry now I don't know I'll just I'll
put this image here and just let you
guys think about the idea the Targaryen
traditionally weds brother to sister
although technically Daenerys is John's
aunt because Daenerys is the daughter of
the Mad King and John is the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen the mad Kings oldest
son so get hype it was a great season
but new round of the giveaway starts now
all you guys have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video my next video will probably be
season 7 predictions there are a couple
really easy ones the show definitely
teed up some really easy stuff where
it's going to pick up next season but I
always try to expect a few
surprises so let me know what you guys
think of the episode in the comments and
we will follow up tomorrow so why you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here to learn a little bit
more about why it was so important that
Jon Snow's mother be kept secret and you
can click here for last week's episode 9
video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you